adele and her insane transformation
is hitting the saturday night live stage
it is i will be musical guest this week
or maybe me
[Music]
oh expect adele to go all out for her
first
hosting gig ever excited and terrified
the 32 year old's been busy studying her
lines and getting her american accent
ready
for her full circle moment oh my god no
worries girlfriend
hello it's me
the show's poked fun at the two-time
musical guest before
but et's learned adele is super close
with creator lauren michaels
he produced her live nbc special in 2015
and adele
credits her 2008 snl debut with
launching her career in the u.s
so she jumped at the chance to host
posting i just couldn't possibly say no
today marks five years since adele
released
hello so will tomorrow be the day the
singer finally announces
a release date for her new album
yeah that was before the pandemic adele
later told fans
corona ain't over i'm quarantining wear
a mask and be patient
cuny nate's feet to be wicked i'm sorry
bad idea
she's massed up for tomorrow night many
expect adele to mention her crazy
transformation
dropping an estimated 100 pounds
how'd she do it after separating from
husband simon adele reportedly started
working out with a personal trainer
and went on a 1 000 calorie a day diet
she also changed her outlook
turning to the celeb beloved book
untamed about female empowerment
she says this book will shake your brain
and make your
soul scream i mean
make your goals scream what could be
better i love that so much